[Music]
David omen can't do anything just
because they can doesn't mean they
should that's just the way outstanding
angels you have a new client who is she
I can't sleep at night I'm a lead
programmer on a product that can
revolutionize the power industry but
there is a possibility it can be
weaponized and I'm you know I'm Jane
who are you
embossing
welcome to the Townsend agency we exist
because traditional law enforcement
can't keep up I don't like that boy you
guys are like lady spies Jane's former
mi6 Oh God
what did you do to spend I compressed
his carotid and deoxygenated his brain
stem well that sounds painful
don't worry he's gonna wake up unless he
doesn't Sabina runs the ground game
sano stuff let's get the weapon before
it becomes every bad guys favorite new
toy
cheer her up we're gonna need some wigs
we're still in the first posit there's
another closet oh just stop the touching
some of these blows up
[Music]
I love fostering are you flirting with a
handsome nerd
[Music]
how'd that feel cuz it looks like it
felt really good I felt nice
[Music]
good morning angels morning charlie
[Music]
[Music]